first of all the movie looks amazing
incredibly stylish incredibly funny
which i think is guy ritchie's that's
kind of his metier right he does stylish
and rye and funny very well right off
the bat you can see army and and Henry
your characters are on opposite sides of
the longest-running conflict in the 20th
century the Cold War so from the very
beginning you guys want to rip each
other apart yeah how and but you have to
work together so how is it forming this
relationship with his actors you know
kind of from a process perspective and
within the character who want to both
kill each other and are forced to work
together to to do something good well I
mean um I mean I had no trouble working
together we certainly enjoyed few drinks
together as well
that's a lot of time but uh to try and
build that that animosity it wasn't so
tough as all written in there and and
guys a fantastic director he knows
exactly how to find that fine line
between the coming to loggerheads and
actually working together making it
funny at the same time mm-hmm I was a
process for you guys
how much comedy have you done I mean
because even though this is a stylish
kind of action thriller guy he
specializes in like hardcore kind of
action bloody comedy that's that's what
he does
was that something that was new for
either of you I mean who sent me an e
for me yeah I hadn't done it before but
a guy makes it that makes it pretty easy
yeah yeah yeah you know I mean most of
the humor was really built in by guy you
know absurdity of some of the situations
the way they had to deal with each other
the dynamics of how everybody related so
we basically just showed up and said the
words on the great script right and just
it played um I want to hear a little bit
more about this piece because it's a
period piece it's a new guys done period
before but it's a new period for guy
it's obviously it said it at some point
in the 60s was there it was areas you
guys was there a year did you when you
got to set these daily at 64 was there
particular year it's the same same year
as Archer um so yeah not as not as good
as Archer no god it's amazing it looks
so great so funny what was like for you
guys was this a new period for you guys
working in the 60s and how did that feel
both I think did that affect the way
that you the choices you made as
characters I'll see also physically you
dress differently you move differently I
I think you know I
parents were young in late 60s and I
grew up always looking back at their
pictures I was kind of know always
wanted to dress like them and I think I
always had a dream when I was a kid to
kind of are I wish I was in the cool
sixties and now you know we'd shot most
of it in Rome in Italy and they just
closed off the Spanish Steps via del
corso everyone was in costume hundreds
of extras it was pretty amazing to walk
in there you I mean it did a lot of the
work itself just to step into those
sense I think I think this 60s and 70s
is like a golden they were golden eras
for villains you know so for me being
able to play a villain in the 60s was
kind of great like all the cliches that
you can play with in the stereotypes but
the costumes were so fantastic and they
sort of add such a level and the hair I
mean I think my hair weighed about 10
kilos I hold it up it's 25 pounds you
guys 25 cents in America okay see but it
was you know and also like you know I
think accent wise we got to work with a
different sound and I you know I got to
work with that really sort of clipped
BBC English kind of sound that was
really fun to play with and write an
army you got to do an accent had you
ever done a Russian accent before no
hadn't no was that for you it was great
you know I mean it really informed the
character it made it more fun to do and
he just made some of this stuff you say
something more badass
right how much I always feel like it
could be very intimidating to do an
accent cuz you're always in your head
thinking God if I just get one thing
wrong I'm gonna fall out of this thing
completely did you work for a while on
ER what did it did was it effortless no
it definitely wasn't effortless uh we
had a dialect coach on set a great guy
named Andrew Jack who was there and
helped us and all that doing the accent
was one thing but when they said hey
come take a look at the scene and you
had to watch it again it's just like oh
yeah I mean it plays beautifully um as
you guys know in a whole age this thing
is so accelerated I want to get right to
an audience question do we have anybody
lined up back there to ask the first
question okay here we are right up here
hey Superman you look awesome thank you
thank you thing I Steve sure dude yeah
I'm just borrowing it just for a little
bit
that's that Superman's workout outfit
apparently okay when you guys were doing
the fight scenes in rehearse
see who got hurt first in real life um I
don't think neither us got hurt mean
basically the scene was all set up to be
this sort of a very precise cool
fighting through these toilet cubicles
and we messed it up on the first one
just none of the walls broke we just
falling all over the floor kicking each
other in the face and stuff and Govan I
love it have you been like that don't
make it cool and that's us that's how we
went yeah it's interesting because there
I think again doing a fight scene in a
period piece you're gonna be fighting
differently than say if you were doing a
modern piece or if you were playing
Superman obviously because he wouldn't
fight anybody you just iray them but um
so was the fighting different did you
feel like the way that you kind of
choreographed these fights and you guys
fought too as well like did you feel
like the way you choreographed it felt
different than waiting my choreograph a
modern film you know it just don't my it
felt organic it didn't it wasn't like
there wasn't a stunt guy going okay now
when you get hit make sure you flip all
the way over backwards and then you'll
grab him on the foot it was just like
you were two guys in the bathroom fight
it out you know and just kind of as one
does yeah if I had a nickel uh another
audience question uh yeah arrow Lou I
think yeah
sweetly um discussion goes up to
everyone up in the panel um what was
like the inspiration to drove you to
connect with your characters and why
let's start I'm I'm your evil at heart
so um I do wasn't a stretch what do I
want to do and I think yeah gabby is a
very unconventional kind of you know
female character one of those big
franchise movies she's very bad as you
don't really know what her intentions on
what side she's on she's yeah she's
pretty badass
yeah Napoleon he's just a typical
mischievous rogue you uh you love to
hate or you hate to love and it was it
essentially with him the key was make it
fun don't take yourself too seriously
and don't be too cool either uh you know
the funny thing about Ilya is he has no
sense of humor
it's
it's all business there's no pleasure
there's no there's no fun there's none
of that so I completely couldn't relate
but it was still fun to get to his
character
oh those joyless Russians uh guys we
have to move on thank you so much for a
huge
you